[موسيقى]
مساء الخير واهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار
وملفات السعوديه والخليج نبدا بالعناوين
وفي طليعه احترام اسياده الدول وعدم
التدخل
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه واكدوا في اجتماعا
لمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي ان الرياض اتفقت
مع طهران على احترام سياده الدول وحل
الخلافات
في مكه المكرمه اطلاق اكبر تجربه افتراضيه
لاختبار عمليات النقل والتفويج استعدادا
لموسم الحج المقبل
محافظ البنك المركزي السعودي ينفي للعربيه
اي تعامل للبنوك السعوديه مع المصارف
الامريكيه المتعثره
في الرابعه ايضا
لاول مره في الشرق الاوسط اطلاقه خدمه
القطار السياحي الفاخر في السعوديه
باتفاقيه مع ارسنال الايطاليه
برنامج الرياضي الخضراء يبدا بزراعه 39
الف شجره في حي الجزيره في الرياض وقريبا
احياء اخرى
مساء الخير اكد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل من فرحان ان المملكه تدعم حل
الخلافات بالحوار ومن هذا المنطلق توصلت
الى اتفاقيه مع ايران بعد جلسات في مسقط
بغداد وبكين معربا في كلمته خلال افتتاح
المجلس الوزاري لدول التعاون الاسلامي عن
تطلعه في ان تنعكس الاتفاقيه ايجابا على
المنطقه
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه تؤمن باهميه
ما يجمعنا من روابط الدين والجوار وتبسط
يدها دوما للحوار يحل الخلافات بالطرق
السلميه ومن هذا المنطلق اجرت لاكثر من
عامين عده جولات للحوار على الشقاء في
ايران في كل من بغداد واسقط ثم مؤخرا
وقد تكلت هذه المباحثات بالاتفاق على
عادات الاعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه من
البلدين على اساس احترام مبادئ ومقاصد
ميثاق المتحده ومنظمه التعاون الاسلامي
وفي طليعه احترام سياده الدول وعدم
التدخلة وحسن الجوار وحل الخلافات الحوار
ونتطلع الى ان يعزز هذا الاتفاق من امن
واستقرار من طبخه الخليج العربي ويدعم
مسيره العمل الاسلاميه المشترك هذا وشدد
وزير الخارجيه السعودي على دعم المملكه
المتواصل للسلام في اليمن ولكل المجهودات
الداعيه لوقف اطلاق النار بشكل دائم
ان المملكه تجدد دعمها للسلام في اليمن
ولجهود المبعوث الامني الى اليمن الراميه
الى التوصل لوقف كامل ودائم لاطلاق النار
وبدء العمليه السياسيه بين الحكومه
اليمنيه والحوثيين وتؤكد على دعم مجلس
القياده الرئاسي اليمني لتمكينه من تنفيذ
سياسات ومبادرات فعاله من شانها تحقيق
الامن والاستقرار في الجمهوريه اليمنيه
وانهاء الازمه
وفيما يتعلق بالقضيه الفلسطينيه اكد وزير
الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن فرحان على حق
الفلسطينيين في دوله مستقله على حدود 67
مدينا في الوقت نفسه او مدينا الانتهاكات
لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه في حق الشعب
الفلسطيني
تؤكد المملكه موقفها الداعم للاصراع في
ايجاد حل عالد وشامل للقضيه الفلسطينيه
وفق قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه ومبادره
السلام العربيه
واقامه دوله فلسطين مستقله على حدود عام
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه والمملكه كانت ولا
زالت تدعم الشعب الفلسطيني لاستعاده حقوقه
المشروعه
والمجتمع الدولي للقيام بدوره في وضع حد
الانتهاكات قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
تجاه الشعب الفلسطيني وتقويض فرص احياء
عمليه السلام
اوضح مساعد وزير الخارجيه الايراني علي
رضا عن نايتي ان اللقاء المرتقب بين وزير
الخارجيه حسين امير عبد الله ونظيرها
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان سيبحث
تفاصيل عوده سفيري البلدين مشيرا الى
تحقيق بعض النتائج المرجوه حتى الان فيما
يتعلق بتحسين العلاقات بين ايران وجاراتها
من الدول عنايه اكد ايضا ان استئناف
العلاقات بين طهران والرياض سيمهد للتعاون
بما يصبوا في مسار التنميه داخل المنطقه
في غضون ذلك افادت صحيفه
بموافقه ايران على وقف تسليح الحوثيين في
اطار الاتفاق على استئناف العلاقات مع
السعوديه كما اشارت الصحيفه ايضا الى ان
نهج ايران حيال الصراع في اليمن سيكون
اختبارا حقيقيا لنواياها بعد عوده
العلاقات مع الرياض وان هذه الاتفاقيات
ستعطي دفعه للتوصل الى صفقه لانهاء النزاع
في اليمن في وقت قريب
من جانبه وصف وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
وساطه الصين في التوصل الى اتفاق بين
السعوديه وايران بالامر الجيد وقال بلينكن
للصحفيين خلال زيارته الى اثيوبيا ان
امريكا تثني على اي خطوه تساعد في تقليل
التوترات وتجنب الصراع وتردع اي تصرفات
خطيره ومزعزعه للاستقرار من جانب ايران
من وجهه نظرنا فان اي شيء يمكن ان يساعد
في تقليل التوترات وتجنب الصراع وكبح
الاعمال الخطيره او المزعزعه للاستقرار من
قبل ايران باي شكل من الاشكال هو امر جيد
وكما تعلمون كان السعوديون والايرانيون
يتحدثون لبعض الوقت منذ عامين في بغداد
وسلطنه عمان وكذلك الصين سهلت ابراما هذه
الاتفاقيه لاستعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
نشرت قياده القوات الامريكيه في اوروبا
مقطعا مصورا لعمليات اسقاط مسيرتها من قبل
القوات الروسيه فوق البحر الاسود الفيديو
يظهر فتح طائره صخوي خزانات الوقود على
الطائره المسيره الامريكيه مما ادى الى
اتلافها
[موسيقى]
هذا وقالت الرئاسه الروسيه ان الجيش
الروسي سيعمل على انتشال حطام مسيره
الامريكيه من قاع البحر الاسود اذا اعتبر
ذلك ضروريا للامن القومي من جهه اخرى اعرب
الكرملين عن اسفه لمساعي السويد وفنلندا
للانضمام الى حلف الناتو مشددا على ان
روسيا لم ولن تشكل تهديدا للبلدين
قالت سلطات خيرسون المواليه لروسيا ان
التحصينات الحديثه التي اقيمت في المقاطعه
لن تسمح للقوات الاوكرانيه بالوصول الى
شبه جزيره القرم في حاله حدوث هجوم مضاد
واعتبر القائم باعمال حاكم منطقه خيرسون
اعتبر ان القوات الاوكرانيه لا يمكن عبور
لا يمكنه عبور نهر دنيبرو وكذلك التحصينات
وانظمه التحكم التي تم تشييدها مؤخرا
صحيفه بوليتكو الامريكيه نشرت نقلا عن
مصادر ان اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
تتوقع قيام اوكرانيا بهجوم مضاد في مايو
المقبل لاستعاده اراضيها كما اوضحت
الصحيفه الامريكيه ان شركاء اوكرانيا
الامريكيين والاوروبيين يقومون بتزويد
كييف بكميات ضخمه من الذخيره والقذائف
مصادر الصحيفه اشارت ايضا الى ان الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد سيكون من خلال احتمالين
اثنين الاول من خلال الهجوم جنوبا عبر نهر
خيرسون الى شبه جزيره القرم اما الاحتمال
الاخر سيكون من خلال شن هجوم القوات
الاوكرانيه باتجاه بحر ازوف وبهدف قطع
الممر البري المؤدي الى شبه الجزيره
في فرنسا صدق مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي
بالاغلبيه على نص التسويه لاصلاح نظام
التقاعد والذي يقضي برفع سن التقاعد من 62
الى 64 عاما وذلك في المرحله ما قبل
الاخيره والتي تليها مرحله طرح النص على
الجمعيه الوطنيه في فرنسا وذلك استجابه
للتظاهرات المستمره المعترضه على قانون
رفع سن التقاعد
اكد المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
ان بلاده تامل بان العلاقات بين اليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه تتطور في اتجاه يفضي الى
السلام في المنطقه
الصين تعارض محاولات دول معينه لتشكيل
دوائر مغلقه ونامل ان تتطور العلاقات بين
اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه في اتجاه يفضي
الى السلام والاستقرار والازدهار في
المنطقه
لا تزال الانشطه الزلزاليه والهزات
الارتداديه متواصله بعد الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا ضرب زلزال عنيف
نيوزلندا بقوه 7.1 درجه ليزيد من حده
القلق بخصوص تداعيات الهزات الارضيه على
قشره الارض حيث كشفت دراسه علميه ان
الزلزال المستمر او الزلازل المستمره
تسببت في اتساع صدع موجود في افريقيا
نتابع التفاصيل مع فارس صلواتي
اخبار الكوارث الطبيعيه لا تتوقف افريقيا
القاره قد تنشطر الى نصفين هذا وفق تقرير
اعده باحثون بريطانيون ونشر في دوريه جيو
فيسكا جورنال لكن لا داعي للفزع فهذا
الامر قد يستغرق بين خمسه الى عشره ملايين
سنه والسبب هو الزلازل التي ادت الى
تصدعات في قشره الارض اخرها الزلزال القوي
الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا وخلف نحو
50 الف قتيل هذا الزلزال وصل التداعياته
الى القاره السمراء زلزال تركيا وسوريا
وقع بين ثلاثه صفائح تيكتونيه وتسبب في
تحرك صفيحه الاناضول ثلاثه امتار غربا
وادى ايضا الى تحرك الصفيحه الافريقيه
وساهم في اتساع ما يعرف بصدع الشرق
افريقيا الذي اصبح اكثر نشاطا مع تزايد
الحركه مستمره داخل القشره الارضيه الصدع
يبلغ طوله سته وخمسين كيلو مترا او 56
كيلومترا وظهر في الصحاري الاثيوبيه في
عام 2018
يمتد نشطه في شرق افريقيا اسفل كل من
اثيوبيا وكينيا وتنزانيا حيث تشير دراسات
الى ان تحركات الصفائح قد بدات من منطقه
عفر شمال اثيوبيا وانتشرت جنوبا نحو
زيمبابوي وبمعدل يتراوح بين سنتيمترين
ونصف الى خمسه سنتيمترات سنويا هذا
الامتداد يقع فوق نقطه تقاطع ثلاث صفائح
التكتونيه تتقشر ببطء شديد وتنزلق بعيدا
عن بعضها البعض وهي عمليه جيولوجيه معقده
يقول العلماء بانها ستقسم القاره السمراء
الى قسمين ما يحدث في الصدع يمثل تماما
الحركه التي كونت البحر الاحمر ولكن بمعدل
اكثر بطئا وفقا ما نشر في دوريه جيوفسكا
جورنال وخلص او خلص العلماء القائمون على
الدراسه الى ان تشكيل محيط جديد في
افريقيا يمكن ان يكون وهو امر مرجح وبعدها
سيتقدم قاع البحر على طول الصدم هنا ستصبح
القره الافريقيه اصغر حجما وستشكل جزيره
كبيره في المحيط الهندي تضم اجزاء من
اثيوبيا والصومال وكذا القرن الافريقي
الرابعه مستمره وتتابعون
السعوديه تبدا اولى مراحل التوطين في مهن
الطيران المرخصه
اهلا بكم من جديد في السعوديه خصصت
الرئاسه العامه لشؤون المسجد الحرام
والمسجد النبوي قصصت 20 الف نقطه لتوزيع
اكثر من اربعين مليون لتر من ماء زمزم
خلال شهر رمضان وذلك باستخدام تقنيه
الروبوت واكثر من 80 عربه ذكيه في انحاء
الحرم كما جهزت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين 30 الف
حافظه لماء زمزم اضافه الى المشربيات
الرخاميه الموزعه في المساحات الداخليه
والخارجيه
وضمن الاستعدادات لموسم الحج المقبل تشهد
المشاعر المقدسه في مكه المكرمه اليوم
اكبر تجربه فرضيه لتحديد افتراضيه لتحديد
مدى جاهزيه العمليات التشغيليه لمنظومه
النقل وتفويج الحجاج وبمشاركه 25 جهه
حكوميه وخاصه التجربه الافتراضيه السعوديه
تختبر ايضا انظمه الحج والتي جاء منها
اختبار مدى سرعه استجابه الفرق الميدانيه
وتشغيل غرفه المراقبه بالاضافه الى جاهزيه
البنيه التحتيه وتكامل الخطوط التشغيليه
ولاول مره في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وقعت
الخطوط الحديديه السعوديه صار ومجموعه
ارسنال الايطاليه المتخصصه في اطلاق رحلات
القطارات الفاخره وقعت مذكره تفاهم لاطلاق
خدمه القطار السياحي الفاخر داخل السعوديه
وبمسمى حلم الصحراء وستتولى الخطوط
الحديديه سعر جميع الخدمات التشغيليه
للمشروع الجديد اما الشركه الايطاليه
ستتولى جميع خدمات ما قبل الافتتاح والتي
تتمثل في تصنيع عربات القطار التسويق
للمشروع وغيرها من الخدمات وتهدف
الاتفاقيه الجديده الى اتاحه الفرصه لزوار
السعوديه وساكنها لاكتشاف المزيد من مناطق
الجذب السياحي التي تتمتع بها البلاد
اعلنت وزاره الموارد البشريه والتنميه
الاجتماعيه السعوديه بدا تطبيق قرار توطين
مهن الطيران المرخصه وبالتعاون مع الجهات
الاشرافيه القرار السعودي المهني نصه في
مرحلته الاولى على توطين اربعه او اربع
مهن منها المراقب الجوي ومساعد الطيران
بالاضافه الى توطين نسبه 60% لمهنه طيار
جناح ثابت وبنسبه 50% لمهنه مضيف طيران
قرروا التوطين الجديد في السعوديه تصاحبه
حزمه من المحفزات التي اطلقتها وزاره
الموارد البشريه للقطاع الخاص منها دعم
الاستقطاب والتدريب والتاهيل وذلك لتوفير
بيئه عمل منتجه للمواطنين والمواطنات
وتعزيز مساهمه السعوديين في المنظومه
الاقتصاديه
من جده ينضم الينا المختص في اداره
المطارات وتشغيل والتحول التقني المعتز
الميرا اهلا بك معنا سيد المعتز يعني هذا
قرار اتى في وقته ام ان هناك يعني نقص في
الكوادر
لهذه المهن مهن الطيران ان كان ان كنا
نتحدث عن مراقب جوي ملاح جوي او حتى مساعد
طيران وغيرها من مهن الطيران
اهلا وسهلا اختي الفاضله يسعد مسائكم
جميعا وشكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه حقيقه
البرنامج
اتى في وقته او بالاصح كان ابن المفترض ان
يبدا ما قبل ذلك ولكن هذا البرنامج برنامج
شرطين هو جدا مهم في هذه الفتره الحاليه
وخاصه مع تسارع العمل في قطاع الطيران
خلال هذه الفتره سواء على المستوى العالمي
او على المستوى المحلي بعد التعافي من
جائحه كورونا خاصه نتكلم في قطاع الطيران
حقيقه بالنسبه للكبادر البشريه فالكوادر
البشريه موجوده ومؤهله بالتاكيد لم تالوا
قدوم حكومه قادم الحرمين الشريفين عبر
جامعاتها بمختلف التخصصات في قطاع الطيران
سواء على سعيد هندسه الطائرات في جامعه
الملك عبد العزيز او جامعه الملك فهد
البترول المعادن الاكاديميه السعوديه
للملاحه الجويه بما يخص مراقبين الجويين
التخصصات المتعلقه
الخدمات الارضيه في جامعه ام القرى او في
جامعه الامير سلطان العديد من الجامعات
تخرج المئات او الالاف من المؤهلين في هذا
القطاع
لكن رجوعا الى ما تحدثت فيها او تفضلت فيه
بقرار التوطين بما يخص الوظائف سواء كانت
كابتن طيار او مساعد كابتن بالتبسيط على
المستمع
فممكن نحن نتكلم في هذا الموضوع بالاخص
انه في خلال خمس سنين الفائته حقيقه
اعتمدت شركات الطيران على توظيف خريجيه
برنامج وظيفتك وهذه حقبه مكتسب لكن في
معضله في هذا الموضوع عند الرجوع عندما
نتكلم عن الطيارين الدارسين على حسابهم
الشخصي هذا الموضوع جدا مهم يعني ممكن نحن
يعني سيد المعتاد صحيح يعني ما تفرق هي ان
كان بالبعثه او الحساب الشخصي او على
حسابه الشخصي ولكن وجود الاعتماد المهني
هو النقطه المحوريه ربما
صحيح الاعتماد المهني طبعا اكيد جميعنا
نتكلم عنهم سواء كانوا دارسين على حسابهم
الشخصي او الدارسين عن طريق وظيفتك بعثتك
هم في الجامعات او المعاهد او المراكز
المعتمده لتدريس الطيارين خليني اذكر لك
مثال مثال حي قريب جدا لاحد برامج التوظيف
للشركه من الشركات طيران المحليه الوطنيه
تقدم فقط لهذا البرنامج التوظيف ووظيفه
لطيار تقريبا الف متقدم انت تتكلم على الف
متقدم كلهم يعني
السعوديين طبعا كلهم مواطنين نتكلم على
الف متقدم يعني تتكلم انه القطاع في الف
طيار عاطل عن العمل لم يقبل منهم الا 10%
حسب احتياج الشركه هذا من الاشياء اللي
موجوده يعني احنا نتكلم علاوه على ان
المتقدمين في الاساس كانوا 1300 طيار يعني
المعتز اتى فيه وقته ولصالحهم
صحيح جدا اكيد انه جاي في صالحهم لكن
يكون في صالحهم بالتعاون مع الجهات ذات
العلاقه سواء كانت شركه شركات طيران او ما
الى ذلك من الضروري جدا يعني كقطاع
الطيران هو قطاع تكامل يا اختي الفاضل
يتطلب من الجميع التكاتف والتعاون لتحقيق
هذا مخرجات هذا البرنامج
وهنا لما نقول الجميع الساده المعتز يعني
نتكلم عن القطاع الجهات الحكوميه والقطاع
الخاص
حقيقه القطاع الخاص يعني الان نحن نتكلم
كتوجه جديد في البلد الان نتكلم عن القطاع
الخاص صار هو
يعني النسبه الاكبر في سوق العمل في قطاع
الطيران سواء على مستوى شركات الطيران
الطيران او حتى على مستوى مشغلين المطارات
كل اسارت شراكه اللي هو
قطع خاص واصبح وجود الحكومه في هذا
الموضوع ودوره كدوره مشرع فقط لا غير اما
على الصعيد تشغيل المطارات على صعيد شركات
الطيران على صعيد حتى الخدمات الرضايفه
كلها شركات خاصه اختي الفاضله فالدور
الاكبر والاهم هو الاستثمار في المواطنه
السعوديه او ابن البلد
لتحقيق هذا القرار وهذا طبعا لا يخفى على
الجميع انه احد
المستهدفات الرئيسيه في رؤيه سمو سيدي ولي
العهد بتخفيض مستوى البطاله لكن في موضوع
اخر نتكلم فيه ايضا يعني ما في طائره تقدر
تطلع من غير مهندسين جاويين حقيقه
المهندسين
المهن في الطيران ويشملهم ربما هذا القرار
قرار التوطين ام لا الساده المعتز
لا بد من يشملهم اكيد انه حيشملهم يعني
قطاع الطيران ترى واسع كثير وفي المئات من
التخصصات مئات من التخصصات يعني ممكن انا
اذكر لك كنسبه يمكن نسبه الطيارين وايضا
الملاحين وحتى ممكن مراقبه الجويين لا
يتعدى ثلاثه في المئه الى اربعه في المئه
من اجمالي
عدد الوظائف في قطاع نعم نعم خليني اذكر
لك ونرجع قليلا على موضوع التخصصات
المتعلقه بهندسه الطيران يعني عندنا
خريجين من معاهد معتمده ومصرحه من الهيئه
العامه للدار المدني ولكن للاسف نجد منهم
العديد الان يشتغل في وظيفه غير تخصصه او
انهم يعملون في مهن اقل يعني مردود المادي
منها اقل ما يستحقونه يعني ممكن نحن نقول
لك انا بعض التجارب اللي موجوده على ارض
الواقع
التي ذكرتها استاذ المعتز يعني هل هم لا
يجدون الوظائف الملائمه
ما هي عده نقاط خليني اذكر لك هي في بشكل
مختصر ما يتعدى لما نحن نتحدث الان ونرجع
لهذا الموضوع انه ليش بيشتغلوا مثلا في
شركات التزود بالقود على سبيل المثال او
الشركات الاخرى في محن غير تخصصاتها بنرجع
ونقول انه في نفس الوقت نلاقي انه العديد
من نفس التخصصات تلاقيهم بالجنسيه مثلا
الغير سعوديه والوافده من
دول اسيا مثلا
ويجوك من الدوله هذه ممكن عشان يعني
القيمه او الراتب يكون بشكل مبسط لكن
المشكله هنا انه تلاقي نفسه هذا الوافد
اللي يشتغل في هذا القطاع او في الصيانه
او في هندسه محركات الطائرات او بدل
الطائرات يكون من الخبره سنه والسنتين
والثلاثه واطلع الى الدول المجاوره الاخرى
في الاقليم او الدول القريبه ويعمل
براتباته ويستفيد من هذه الخبره مع انك
تجد انه هذول الموظفين
المؤهلين السعوديين فامس الحاجه انا اجيك
بس ايجابي
وسيبقون في هذه المنطقه وهذه البلد شكرا
لك من جده للاسف الوقت يدعمنا المختص في
اداره المطارات والتشغيل والتحول التقني
المعتز الميرا
نفق محافظ البنك المركزي السعودي ايمن
السياري للعربيه اي تعامل للبنوك السعوديه
مع المصارف الامريكيه المتعثره كما شدد
السياري على متانه القطاع المصرفي وتوفير
ادوات تكميليه لتوفير السيوله مشيرا الى
ان مستويات السيوله مطمئنه وان القروض غير
المنتظمه لا تتجاوز 1.8
اؤكد مره اخرى ان البنك المركزي يتابع
تطورات السيوله
ويعمل بشكل وثيق مع المصارف التجاريه
لتحليل المسببات
وتفعيل الادوات الناجعه
لمعالجتها طبعا واله الحمد النظام البنكي
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ومعروف حقيقه من عده سنوات
معروف بمثالته
والكفايه العاليه لرؤوس امواده
ومستويات سيوله مطمئنه
كان الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه السعوديه
للصناعات العسكريه وليد ابو خالد ان
الشركه التابعه لصندوق الاستثمارات العامه
باتت ضمن افضل 100 شركه دفاعيه في العالم
وذلك بعد مرور اربعه اعوام على انطلاقها
الى ان هدف الشركه هو الوصول الى قائمه
افضل 50 شركه دفاعيه في العالم وكذلك
الوصول الى مئه في المئه كنسبه توطين
للصناعات العسكريه في البلاد
تتابعون بعض الفاصل
جده تضع الاستعدادات الاخيره قبل انطلاق
فورمولا 1 للمره الثالثه
احترام سياده الدول وعدم التدخل
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يؤكد في اجتماع
لمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي ان الرياض اتفقت
مع طهران على احترام سياده الدول وحل
الخلافات
في مكه المكرمه اطلاق اكبر تجربه افتراضيه
لاختبار عمليه النقل والتفويج استعدادا
لموسم الحج المقبل
محافظ البنك المركزي السعودي ينفي للعربيه
اي تعامل للبنوك السعوديه مع المصارف
الامريكيه المتعثره
ولاول مره في الشرق الاوسط اطلاق خدمه
القطار السياحي الفاخر في السعوديه
باتفاقيه مع ارسنال الايطاليه
احييكم من جديد اعلنا برنامج الرياض
الخضراء عن انطلاق اعمال التشجير في حي
الجزيره كذلك احياء الاحياء السكنيه التي
يتم تشجيرها في العاصمه السعوديه ويهدف
البرنامج لزراعه اكثر من 39 الف شجره
وشجيره في حي الجزيره وانشاء احدى عشره
حديقه وتشجير 37 مسجدا و14 مدرسه وايضا 36
كم من الطرق والممرات وبعد الجزيره سيباشر
برنامج الرياض الخضراء بتسجيل في احياء
العرجاء وقرطبه والغدير والنخيل
من حي الجزيره في الرياض ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه نواف عزيز اهلا بك معنا نواف انقل
لنا الصوره لديك والتشجير في حي الجزيره
نعم فاطمه مشروع الرياضي الخضراء وصل الى
حي الجزيره بعد الانتهاء من بدء التشجير
في حي العزيزيه جنوب الرياض وحي النسيم
الان في حي الجزيره كعاده مشروع الرياض
الخضراء تنظم فعاليه لاهالي حي الجزيره
تستمر على مدى عشر ايام توضح لهم التفاصيل
حول تشجير هذا الحي من خلال معرض تفاعلي
ياخذ الزوار برحله عبر الزمن كما سنشاهد
في هذا المعرض الذي يعرف اهالي حي الجزيره
على مشروع الرياض الخضراء اهداف المشروع
انجازات المشروع كما نشاهد الان ونعلم ان
مشروع الرياض الخضراء اطلق من قبل الملك
سلمان في عام 2019
وهو بمبادره من ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان ضمن رؤيه 20 بعد التعرف على
اهداف المشروع وانجازات المشروع تبدا رحله
الزوار للتعرف على
مستقبل الحي الخاص بهم حي الجزيره هنا
اعداد الاشجار التي ستزرع اضافه الى
الشبكات المياه والمدارس التي سيتم
تشجيرها 11 حديقه هو عشرات المدارس سيتم
تشجيرها وايضا الطرق الفرعيه والداخليه في
الاحياء كما نشاهد من خلال هذه الخارطه
التفاعليه التي توضح المخطط الخاص بحي
الجزيره ويمكن لاهالي الحي كما نشاهد الان
التعرف بشكل تفاعلي على الشوارع
والطرق في حي الجزيره التي سيتم تشجيرها
اضافه الى الم
المساجد والحدائق التي ستنشا زراعه اكثر
من 39 الف الشجره وشجيره داخل حي الجزيره
على مدى اقل من عامين ونصف وهي تعتبر مده
ليست بطويله نظرا لضخامه هذا المشروع هنا
ايضا في المعرض يمكن للزوار على مدى عشره
ايام وايضا طلبت
المدارس
وجميع الفئات من الصغار والكبار التعرف
على الشكل المستقبلي للحدائق وهو تصميم
تصوري واقعي ومعتمد بشكل مؤكد
وسيتم البدء العمل عليه بدءا من اليوم
وفعليا تمت زراعه اول شجره اليوم بافتتاح
من مشروع الرياض الخضراء كما نشاهد ايضا
هنا تجربه جميله يمكن لاهالي حي الجزيره
التعرف على شكل المواقع قبل وبعد التشجير
كما نشاهد على سبيل المثال هذه احدى
المدارس في حي الجزيره هذا هو شكل المدرسه
قبل وهذا هو شكل المدرسه بعد انتهاء
التشجير بشكل كامل هنا ايضا مناطق مخصصه
للاطفال وهي فعاليات متنوعه يمكن للاطفال
قضاء اوقات ممتعه هنا بانشطه ترفيهيه كما
سنشاهد في هذا القسم المخصص للاطفال
والانشطه الترفيهيه هنا ايضا مرتبطه
بالتشجير وهي بالفعل تنمي ثقافه التشجير
والزراعه لدى الاطفال من خلال هذا
المكان كما نشاهد الان هذا الطفل الذي
يقوم بنشاط ترفيهي تتواجد هنا اشجار ويقوم
بممارسه هذه الانشطه هي ضمن المستهدفات
الرئيسيه لمشروع الرياض الخضراء من
مشاهداتك على الارض وانت هناك كيف رايت
اقبال اهل الحي على هذه المبادره وتفاعلهم
مع هذا المعرض
نعم بدءا من صباح اليوم كان هناك حضور
كبير لاهالي الحي من مسؤولين في المدارس
وايضا في الدوائر الحكوميه في حي الجزيره
وبدءا من هذه الساعه نلاحظ الان تزايد
اعداد اهالي الحي الذين يزورون هذه
الفعاليه التي تعتبر في اليوم الاول
وتستمر على مدى عشره ايام هناك في الحقيقه
حماس من قبل اهالي حي الجزيره للتعرف على
الشكل المستقبلي للجزيره خاصه مع هذه
التقنيات المستخدمه في هذا المعرض ومعتمده
في جميع
الاحياء التي سيبدا التشجير فيها طيب ماذا
عن اليه التشجير يعني هل توفرت لديك
معلومات ربما عن الاحياء القادمه عن اليه
تقسيم هذه الاحياء
بخصوص مبادره التشجير
نعم حتى الان الاحياء المعتمده ضمن العقد
الموقع والذي وهو عقد تنفيذي وهي سبع
احياء الان شجرت بدات تشجير في ثلاث احيام
متبقي اربع احيان اتحدث عن احياء في جنوب
الرياض حي العريجه ايضا حي النخيل قرطبه
هو ايضا حي الغدير يتوقع خلال الفتره
القادمه ان تتزايد اعداد الاحياء التي يتم
تشجيرها وستكون على مجموعات كبيره للوصول
الى 120 وهي الاحياء المخطط او الذي يخطط
مشروع الرياض الخضراء لتشجيرها خلال
الفتره القادمه وضمن مشروع الرياض الخضراء
شكرا لك من حي الجزيره في الرياض مراسل
العربيه نواف عزيز
الى جده حيث تستعد غدا الجمعه للكثير من
الاثاره مع انطلاق الحدث الرياضي الابرز
سباق فورميلا 1 والذي يقام للمره الثالثه
في حلبه كورنيش جده السباق يستمر من
السابع عشر من مارس وحتى التاسع عشر وسط
ترقب عالميا من محبي وعشاق سباقات
الفورميلا والفائز بالجائزه السعوديه
الكبرى مزيد من المزايا ستزخر بها حلبه
كورنيش جدا لموسم السباق هذا العام نتعرف
عليها مع الزميله العنود العبدلي
اذا تستعد السعوديه غدا مشاهدينا لاحياء
شبكه الانطلاق لسباق فورمولا وان للسيارات
على جائزه السعوديه الكبرى التي ستقام
للمره الثالثه سيجلب السباق عشاق حلبات
السيارات والسياح من داخل المملكه والخليج
والعالم سباق فورمولا 1 اقيم في جده لاول
مره في ديسمبر عام 2021
يقام السباق على حلبه كورنيش جده وهي ثاني
اطول حلبه في الموسم وتحتوي على سبعه
وعشرين منعطفا 16 نحو اليسار واحد عشر نحو
اليمين لتسخر الحلبه هذا العام باكبر عدد
من معطفات في العالم يبلغ طول مسار الحلبه
سته كيلو مترات
و175 مترا مما يجعلها ثاني اطول حلبه
فورمولا 1 فروزنميه الحاليه بعد حلبه سباع
فرانكورشان البلجيكيه العريقه حلبه كورني
مشاهدينا ابتكرها المصمم العالمي الشهير
هيرمان تتميز بالعديد من المزايا التي
ظهرت لاول مره في عام سباقات الفورمولا 1
فهي تتضمن مدرجه دراجات او درجات عاليه من
التحفيز للسائقين للانطلاق باعلى سرعات
ممكنه وزياده مستويات التشويق خلال السباق
تم تخصيص ثلاث مناطق متتاليه على الحلبه
وتهيئتها بشكل يتيح لسيارات
سباق تجاوز السيارات بسرعه تفوق او تفوق
200 وخمسين كيلو مترا في الساعه ما يجعلها
اسرع حلبه شوارع في العالم موسم هذا العام
مشاهدينا يشهد انضمام ثلاثه مشاركين جدد
الى شبكه السائقين في اول موسم لهم في
الفورمولا 1 وهم
21 عاما وهو اصغر سائق على شبكه الفورمولا
1 في موسم 20 23 مع انضمامه
والسائق الهولندي نكد ديفرس وهو ليس غريبا
على عالم الفورمولا 1 كونه
شارك في العديد من اختبارات لمرسيدس
واوستن مارتن وللمره الاولى منذ عام 2015
سيشارك سائق امريكي في سباق الفورمولا 1
بعد انضمام لوجان الى فريق ويليامز لموسم
20/3 وعشرين في كل عام مشاهدينا تطفي
عمليه اعاده تشكيل سائق فرق الفورميلون
بعض التغيرات المثيره للاهتمام في
ديناميكيات الفريق والسائقين ولا تستثنى
من هذه العمليه تشكيله 20 ثلاثه وعشرين
الجديده
برنامج تدريبي جديد في السعوديه يستهدف
خريجي الجامعات السعوديين عبر توظيفهم في
المصانع بعد تحويل تخصصاتهم الجامعيه الى
تخصصات فنيه وذلك وفقا لمتطلبات سوق العمل
وبخطه دراسيه قصيره
لم يعد صعبا على خريج الجامعات في
السعوديه الالتحاق بوظائف تختلف عن
تخصصاتهم الجامعيه مع تطبيق برنامج تاهيل
القوى العامله المرتكزي على اعاده تاهيل
خريج الجامعات ببرامج تدريبيه تمكنهم من
الالتحاق بالمصانع والشركات الكبرى التي
وظفت 100 سعودي وسعوديه يمثلون الدفعه
الاولى من البرنامج سيكون هناك دفعات
متتاليه حول هذا البرنامج
لما له من اهميه كبيره
ولتوظيف الطلاب او الخريجين هذا البرنامج
في قطاعات العمل وكلهم مئه في المئه بحمد
الله اخذوا مقاعدهم
واخذوا فرصهم في قطاع العمل وفي المصانع
والتعدين من خلال الشركات المشاركه في هذا
البرنامج سته اشهر هي مده تدريب خريجي
الجامعات قبل مباشره وظائفهم يمكن لخريج
العلوم الاجتماعيه والطبيعيه او خريجي
اللغات العمل كاختصاصيين للجوده او
السلامه وحتى ذكاء الاعمال بفضل البرنامج
الذي جذب احدى عشره شركه كبرى تلتزم
بتوظيف المتدربين ورعايتهم خلال مده
الدراسه بعقود طويله مع جهات التدريب الان
تونا يعني يمكن ثلاثه شهور تقريبا
ومستمرين ان شاء الله الى ثلاثه اشهر اخرى
ميدانيه وبعدها يستمر كل متدرب مع نفس
الشركه اللي هو موقع العقد معهم تخصصي من
جامعه الملك سعود انضممت للمعهد من توصيات
عده من متخرجين سابقين
فدخلت هنا تحت تخصص ضبط جوده تتقاطع اهداف
برامج تاهيل القوى العامله التابعه لمؤسسه
التدريب التقني والمهني بين توظيف
السعوديين العاطلين عن العمل وسد احتياجات
السوق مع الزام الشركات الراعيه بحد ادنى
لرواتب خريجي البرنامج من الرياض نواف
عزيز العربيه
اليوم هو اخر يوم في موسم العقارب ويوم غد
الجمعه اول موسم للحميمين التفاصيل في
تقويم دائما مع خالد ازعاج
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اليوم تودعنا العقارب وتقول لنا مع
السلامه
ولا رايح تزورنا الا بعد سنه تقريبا وغدا
الجمعه اول موسم الحميمين وهو اول مواسم
الربيع الحار وسمي بهذا نتيجه لحم وجه
السماء وحمو باطن الارض ونتيجه لهذا
الحامو تخرج الزواحف والهوام مسامه
العقارب والثعابين من مخابيئها ولهذا
يسميه عرب الباديه بالشام بسعد الخبايا
وقالوا في سعد الخبايا تطلع الحيايا
الحميمه الاول اخر موسم برد بياع الخبل
عباته الحميمه الثاني اول برد موسم العجوز
وهو برد نادر الحدود ولا يحدث الا مره
وحده كل 12 سنه واذا حدث فهو مهلك وقالوا
يا ربنا يا رحيم يكفينا برد
الحميمين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فصل الربيع موسمين موسم العقارب وموسم
الحاميمين العقارب معتدله لا تخلو من
هجمات برد مباغته والحميمين ايضا معتدله
لا تخلو من عبور نسمات برد عابره ومطره
منبت للربيع صيفي وغمامه ملطف للاجواء
ساصبروا حتى تتجلى كل غمه وتاتي بما تهواه
نفس المقادير واني لبئس العبد ان كنت ايسا
من الله ان دارت علي
الدوائر
[موسيقى]
ختام رابعه نذكر بالعناوين
وزير الخارجيه السعودي يؤكد في اجتماع
لمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي ان الرياضه اتفقت
مع طهران على احترامي سياده الدول وحل
الخلافات
في مكه المكرمه اطلاق اكبر تجربه افتراضيه
لاختبار عمليات النقل والتفويج استعدادا
لموسم الحج المقبل
محافظ البنك المركزي السعودي في للعربيه
اي تعامل للبنوك السعوديه مع المصاريف
الامريكيه المتعثره
ولاول مره في الشرق الاوسط اطلاق خدمه
القطار السياحي الفاخر باتفاقيه مع ارسنال
الايطاليه
دمتم في امان الله